we have to be responsible and say that
some of those were to do with things
that we've done in particular increasing
some of our fees and part of tomorrow's
announcement is about bringing certain
fees back down to a level where I think
we're going to rista Mule ate some of
that volume but there's also a broader
market story all exchanges are exposed
to market trends and certainly talking
to our members and their customers
there's a real feeling that there are
some activity coming back into the
metals markets so I hope we're going to
see some positive momentum there as well
this is course is the last open act dry
exchange anywhere in Europe does it
still have a place in the modern world
yeah we we strongly believe so you know
we don't keep the ring just for the
tradition or for the history we keep it
because our end users those physical
customers they tell us that in their
view this is the most appropriate and
transparent way of pricing and you know
we're sitting here on on the mezzanine
of the ring and we've had some fantastic
visitors coming here from industry
politicians from key mining countries
and they're attracted by that ability to
see the price being formed in real time
and the transparency that that brings
there's an awful lot of speculation that
you're going to announce that you're
going to launch a lithium contracts is
that very likely so lithium is certainly
a metal that's attracting a lot of
interest right now driven clearly by the
electric vehicle story electric vehicles
mean batteries and batteries mean metals
and we strongly believe given the
announcements we've seen from
governments in the last year or so in 20
30 years time battery metals could be as
important for transportation as oil is
now so are we talking months years I
would like to see a lithium contract up
at the LME within 18 months I think
it's right that because we are the
center of global metals that we're as I
say right at the forefront of getting
that up and running you just mentioned
the fact that the advent of electric
vehicles means that metals demand for
metals is going to change substantially
how are you going to react to that what
do you see happening
yeah so we're already spoken about the
battery metals which are obviously the
most exciting part of the technology as
the hybrid and electric vehicles come on
stream but actually there's a very
strong general automotive story so
copper is going to be far more in demand
in electric vehicles because it is used
throughout the electric systems for the
for the new propulsion and similarly
aluminium we've seen a structural shift
from the use of steel to aluminium for
the body in white which gives you better
fuel economy and obviously aluminium is
one of our key metals so I think
automotive is a really important story
for us here at the LME so I say both in
the battery but also in the body and it
is one that we think will drive our
market forwards so this history every
turn in this building was surrounded by
old
LME golf trophies what you do here at
the enemy though could just as easily be
done anywhere else in the world
what about London's future post brexit
we love our tradition but we're not here
because of our tradition we're here
because London is still genuinely the
best place for us to run this business
there is a huge time zone advantage in
that the prices we discover at midday
here go forward and back to Asia and the
US so we have that global coverage to
disseminate our prices the metal that
sits in our warehouses and is delivered
as a result of the contracts all around
the world is unified by being held under
an English law construct which is what
the global metals trade really want so
those fundamental advantages of being
here in London they're not going to go
away after brexit we've got to work with
our members to make sure our continental
European partners can continue to access
our market but I'm confident that EU or
no EU global metals trade is going to
come here to London